tu es prête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre mari était
abordé dans le Pacifique
au début c'était trop dur de mirriter
je refusais d'accepter que tu n'étais
plus là
mais j'ai commencé à croire que les
bonjour pouvaient peut-être devenir de
bonnes semaines ou de bons mois j'aborde
le monde avec un cœur ouvert maintenant
[Musique]
amoureux d'Emma depuis quelques années
la famille à la famille
allô chérie c'est moi je suis en vie
[Musique]
vous aviez une vie magnifique et ensuite
on croyait tout ce qu'il était mort et
toi tu as trouvé l'amour à nouveau
auprès d'un gars génial peu importe ce
que tu fais tu vas briser le cœur de
quelqu'un
c'était
inutilement verbeux mais assez juste
qu'elle m'aime plus qu'elle l'aime lui
tout ça c'était incroyablement
inapproprié alors j'arrête tout de suite
pour l'amour du ciel
continue
est-ce que tu l'aimes ou non elle
devrait être avec la personne qu'elle
aime le plus forcément avec la personne
qui l'aime le plus elle
alors tu as juste à lui
[Musique]
dire quoi